leute und herzlich willkommen zu einem
kurzen video wir vielleicht beim kann
ich schon gesehen hat geht's bei uns
heute drunter und drüber
es ist der tat denkt und richtig viel
hardware gegönnt
max den ganzen pc bekannt ich habe mir
einige upgrades von pc-welt übrigens
deutlich machen dass gerade films die
ständig kurz mal vor und zwar an
allererster stelle steht da diese
richtig gerne ssd ich weiß ich dass den
preis verdecken youtube mann war mit ihr
wisst ja nicht aber ihr dies habe ich
mir gegönnt weil ich habe mir das
problem und würde ich so 180 frames nur
zocken hatte neuaufnahme erreicht haben
so lag bei der haut wenn ich den
bildschirm geladen haben deswegen hat
ich habe guten guten prozessor kommt
kein laptop grafikkarte guten
arbeitsspeicher dazu später mehr
deswegen führt dieses teil gekauft der
ssd geht richtig ab da ist mein
hauptspeicher mit 256 gb sehr geil
und dazu habe ich mir gedacht könnte ich
mir auch noch ein bisschen
arbeitsspeicher von 4 auf 8 gb auch
richtig geil das bringt richtig ja wie
gesagt kingston glaube ich nach
pfingsten aus und ja es bringt so viel
kraft also die ssd ich komme auf mich
macht ihm klar
damit der neue betriebssystem drauf und
ich komme jetzt in zehn sekunden vom
indianer windows und runter fahren
dauert zwei oder drei sekunden hat habe
ich natürlich weil die neue ssd rhein
ist diese alte schrotmühle hitachi
irgendwas ist schon krass
ihr müsst immer geben oft aus diesem
ding ja den fahrzeuge sind 56 gigabyte
auf und das ist immer das neueste modell
das ist mein arzt hat ihm 51 57 erkennen
und kein geschäft hoffen weil das ist
das alter oder dies rausgekommen und die
werde ich jetzt hier mit patient
anschließend man schließen kann und wir
um krieg zu ermöglichen
und dann die daten übertragen fraps
premiere geweißt alles gekauft
ja das war ein fahrer
ja nicht noch mal kurz mal die systeme
hatten ich habe einen quad core i would
ever mit 4 x 7 hier steht wie 70
ich kann auch mal kurz darauf halten
eigentlich aber ich geschafft aber das
system staub vielleicht will man auch
etwas und jo in der zeit llc mich mal
bis an was wir müssten das leistungs
update ergebnis mit nist hier hier hier
hier hier windows leistungsindex prüfen
lasse sich kurz mal sehen so gelassen
sodass hier ist der us-leitindex ihr
seht das läuft auf jeden fall
67 insgesamt bewertungen hier prozessor
75 arbeitsspeicher 76 die grafik ich
selbst sieben sogar viel besser geworden
ist nicht nur für spiele auf 67 primäre
festplatte 79 also die ssd eskaliert als
die beste komponente meinem system und
jetzt gibt noch mal kurz an dich zurück
der prozessor qualcomm laptop völlig
richtig die grafik gt 540 in reicht
vollkommen aus acht gigabyte kingston
ddr3 speicher und die 256 gb ssd cache
sein schreiben jetzt mal die kommentare
was euer system ist damit ebenso wissen
vergleichen könnte also ein messer
nein mein system privatquartiere aber
ihr habt wahrscheinlich bei magna
gesehen hätte über rechte die besten
quad core prozessor integriert auf dem
markt anbietet und ja dagegen kann ich
dich nicht anstinken ich freue mich
trotzdem dass ich ein glücklicher
trotzdem schnell
märz so sieht der übrigens auf mich und
mein chef des kreis merzig und
hoffenheim nichts gesehen
ansonsten bot er war ja ja das ist auch
im
vom festplatz und ich würde sagen
schreib mir die kommentare was euer
system ist schon nochmal in die
kommentare ob ihr das ding ab ist
interessiert mich und ich habe eine und
wie kann sich der unterschied gezeigt
hat meines größer als seiner
ich habe zwei terabyte speichern egal
franzosen ist die website das ist das
einzige und ja was mich das wissen und
in diesem sinne hauptrollen kommt euer
board drei leute macht's gut und salons